- Hi, good afternoon everyone.
My name is a Afeef Ahmed,
and I'm on stage here
today with Bipin Nepani
and Venky Krishnan.
- Hi everyone.
- Today we're gonna be
talking about WhatsApp,
about how to scale customer
engagement on WhatsApp.
So I'm gonna be starting off today
and then I'm gonna be passing
off to these two gentlemen
who will be going
through some more of the,
about our integration with AWS
and about how you guys
can actually get started
with WhatsApp business.
- Alright, cool.
- Sounds good.
- See you in a minute.
- We'll see you guys
in a few minutes here.
So, business messaging is
all about communication,
and communication between a customer
and a business is nothing new,
that's been going on for, you
know, since all of history.
Once upon a time that was just
face-to-face communication,
and then over time there
became mail and phone,
and websites and apps.
I can actually think of
this exact same example
with my hairstylist.
Once upon a time I had to call
them to make an appointment,
then they finally made a
website, not a great one,
but I can make appointments there.
They skipped the app section
but now I actually communicate
with my hairstylist over WhatsApp.
I make my appointments there,
I can see how long it was
since my last appointment was
so I can tell them, you know,
cut a lot of hair or not.
I can see in one persistent thread
if I'd liked or did not
like a previous haircut
with a picture, so it gives me kind of
a rich way to interact with the business
and for the business to interact with me
because of that persistent thread.
So business messaging,
you know, which is that,
the era of communication that we're in,
it really just enriches
all of the previous methods that we had,
largely because of that persistent thread,
and that's gonna be something
that we talk about a lot today.
You got, I mean, the fact that
you guys joined the session,
probably, you know that what WhatsApp is,
has a dominant position
all around the world.
Three billion monthly active users,
600 million conversations
between customers and
businesses every single day,
and even in the US we
have over a 100 million
monthly active users,
and that number is rapidly growing,
actually much faster than in
much of the rest of the world
where WhatsApp already has primacy
as a communication channel.
And so why are these numbers important?
It's because if you are a business
who wants to get in touch
with your customers,
you want to use the channel
that they're already using.
That's the way that you're
going to get high read rates,
that's the way you're
going to get interaction,
that's the way you're gonna
get customers to interact with
and perhaps transact with your business.
So for a business
considering or thinking about
how they can get in touch with a customer,
we've put this flywheel up here
and it has a lot of words
that actually remind me
of my marketing class
from business school.
But you can see from
awareness through discovery,
consideration, purchase,
post-purchase, and re-engagement,
all of those sections of
the customer lifecycle
you can kind of think of
broadly as how you do marketing,
how you do sales, how you
do follow up with customers.
And really WhatsApp
facilitates communication
for any of those elements
of the customer journey.
Not only does WhatsApp
facilitate those elements
for kind of marketing or sales use cases,
but it really facilitates use cases,
other kinds of use cases that,
where a business would want to get
in touch with the customer.
A few come to mind,
authentication messages,
you can think of these
as one-time passcodes,
utility messages, this is
not necessarily to derive
a sale or anything, but
it might be a message that
you have an appointment coming up
or that your package is about to arrive.
Those kinds of, and also,
oh, I forgot to mention,
customer service messages
where you might want to get in touch
with a business yourself
and ask a question about when
something is going to arrive.
All of these different
types of communication
lead to kind of
a business being able to
serve the entire journey
of how a customer would
want to interact with you.
And notably, you know, I think,
some marketers may think,
well, why do I necessarily
care about one-time passcodes
or utility messages, right,
I care about marketing messages
and saying those to customers.
But what we've actually
seen through our businesses
that use WhatsApp is that
for businesses that employ
multiple types of messages,
that send utility messages
and marketing messages,
they then actually get higher read rates,
higher action rates when
they send marketing messages.
Because as I mentioned
in the example with the,
you know, with my hairstylist,
there is one persistent thread
and that notion of a persistent thread
builds trust with the customer.
Once trust with the
customer is established,
then they are likely to look at,
or consider whatever it is that
you're sending over to them.
WhatsApp has, as you can see, a pretty,
the metrics look great, it's
a really engaging platform,
you know, 80% read rate, a click-through,
or sorry, a click rate of 50%
and a conversion rate of 30%.
The conversion rate, I should note,
is actually sort of a
customer action rate,
so that could be, you know,
a conversion could be any number of things
of whatever a business is
wanting a customer to do.
And because WhatsApp has this
really deep engaging platform,
it's a compelling solution for businesses
to try to get in touch
with their customers.
Now, if you're a business
that's thinking about WhatsApp,
of course data privacy and
security are gonna be paramount,
and they should be.
Those are things that the
product teams that I work with,
they're also constantly thinking about.
You may know, especially if
you're a consumer of WhatsApp,
that we have end-to-end
encryption on messages.
But what you may not know
is that we actually build in
a lot of redundancy through
our security protocols
and our security procedures
to ensure the utmost level of privacy
for the messages being sent over WhatsApp,
between a business and between a client
or just between customers
for the consumer version
of WhatsApp as well.
Now, of course, we couldn't
be at re:Invent 2025
and not mention AI at all,
but WhatsApp is really an ideal channel
for AI-enabled conversations.
And I'd say there's three reasons why
that are illuminated on this slide here,
one is the widespread usage.
You saw this on an earlier slide,
but with three billion
monthly active users,
this is the way that you as a business
can get in touch with
your customers at scale.
The second is, there are rich features.
So again, if you're a user of WhatsApp,
you may have seen some of these like
click-to-action buttons,
or you may have seen a PDF that
was attached by a business,
these are the kinds of rich features that
an AI agent on WhatsApp
could also utilize.
And finally, we have a
rich partner ecosystem.
There are many partners today
that are already using
AI agents on WhatsApp,
and this is the way if, you know,
if you're a business that's
following that flywheel
I showed on the previous
slide of the multiple ways
in which a business can get
in touch with a customer,
you need to be able to do that at scale
and an AI agent would be a
way to be able to do that.
So now I want to talk a little bit about
the different kinds of messages
that WhatsApp facilitates.
And again, this is really important
'cause as I mentioned before,
the more variety of message
types that a business employs
with getting in touch with a customer,
the more that relationship
is formed with the customer
and the more they're
likely to take action,
including with marketing messages.
But lemme start from the left there.
So on the left you see service messages,
these ones are user initiated messages.
So I gave the example before
where you might get in touch and say,
Hey, you know, I need to rebook my flight
or my package didn't arrive.
Then the three message types at the right
are all business initiated
or are all business
initiated conversations.
So that second one is
utility conversations.
Utility conversations are
transactional messages.
So you could think of these
as, your package has arrived,
or you have an appointment
coming up tomorrow.
Moving on from that, you'll
see marketing messages.
Marketing messages is, you know,
it's kind of the bread and butter of,
you know, Meta given that
we were an ads business
and are, you know, are
moving on from that,
but marketing messages are
kind of any kind of a promotion
or an offer that would
be served to a customer.
And finally the last one
is authentication messages.
Authentication messages,
as I mentioned before,
are one-time passcodes,
but those one-time passcodes can serve
a number of use cases.
So now we're gonna do a bit of a deep dive
into each one of those business
initiated conversation types
that I mentioned before.
First, utility messages.
So utility messages can
serve multiple cases,
they can be for order management,
they can be for payment alerts,
for appointment reminders or fraud alerts.
And as you can see from the images here
with this kind of like the,
you know, the rich imaging,
the ability to have
attachments within the thread,
it's a way for a customer
to be really engaged with
and to develop trust in you
as a business interacting with them.
Here's a comparison specifically
for utility messages
of WhatsApp against other
communication channels,
notably RCS and SMS.
I think, a couple things
to highlight here is that,
WhatsApp supports rich media,
with the longer care, it
has longer character counts
and the end-to-end encryption
that is fundamental to WhatsApp.
Now let's move on to marketing messages.
So before we kind of go into that
deep detail of what marketing,
of how marketing messages work,
what are marketing messages,
they're the way in which a
business can get in touch with
and you know, develop a
rapport with a customer.
Notably, that customer
needs to be opted in.
So this is a little bit different from ads
where, you know, a customer
does not have to consent
to be served an ad,
but for a marketing message
they do have to consent.
And because they have to
consent, you can imagine
that there is a high
likelihood that that customer
will want to interact with
the marketing message,
be it a promotion, be it a sale,
be it abandoned a shopping cart message
that you would send to that customer.
Now, previously the marketing messages
that were sent over WhatsApp
were just kind of blunt
templated marketing messages
that were sent to a customer.
And you know, if a certain
number of messages were sent,
then our API might say, okay,
don't send any more
messages to that customer
they've already received too many today.
What it did not take into account however,
was the likelihood that that customer
may want to interact with the message.
And so now we've actually
very recently introduced
optimizations in our marketing messages.
These are the same kinds
of optimizations that,
you know, we have for
our ads engine as well.
And so what's happening here
is we're actually taking
into consideration
the likelihood that
you will open a message
or read that message
at the specific time that that
message would be sent to you.
And so a decision is made
whether to send that
message to that person
or to send it to somebody else
who has a higher likelihood
of actually looking at
that marketing message.
And we've seen some, although
this is a pretty new feature,
we've seen promising results.
There was a study done in India
and you know, for those of you
who've spent time in India,
it's actually very common
to send marketing messages
over WhatsApp there.
And we've seen up to a
9% higher delivery rate
of those marketing messages.
And again, there's a higher delivery rate
because we're not hitting
that blunt cap of,
hey, too many messages sent,
don't send it to that person.
Instead we're sending the
messages in the first place
to the individuals that we think
will interact with that message
and would want to read it.
Now the next message
type that I'll talk about
are authentication messages.
Authentication messages could
serve multiple use cases,
they're all one-time
passcode type messages,
but those one-time passcodes
could serve different use cases.
You could think of new account creation,
you can think of account recovery,
new transactions, or even
for an existing transaction.
You know, actually I was in the UK before
and for my orders that came via Deliveroo,
actually the WhatsApp code came,
or sorry, the one-time passcode
came via WhatsApp as well.
So here again is a comparison of
WhatsApp versus RCS and SMS
specifically for authentication messages.
with WhatsApp you're able
to have that single thread,
you can do copy and code
and there's autofill features
which are really helpful
for one-time passcodes.
There's no app switching necessary.
And you know, true to what WhatsApp is,
there's very low latency
and high reliability in
those messages being sent,
which if you're sending
a one-time passcode
or a utility message,
it's really important that those messages
arrive to your customer
and arrive to your customer at the time
that you intend to send them to 'em.
Now, I've talked to
you a quite a bit about
what WhatsApp is and the
different kind of message types
we have in native
integration with AWS as well.
And so for those of you that
are existing AWS customers,
it's very easy to get set up
and Venky is going to come up here
and talk about AWS End User Messaging,
which is the service that
WhatsApp is integrated with.
- So as a show of hands,
how many of you are familiar with
AWS end user messaging at all?
Alright, so I see a few hands up there.
So just to let you know,
there are two major
communications services APIs
that are available on AWS today.
One is called as Amazon
Simple Email Service,
and the other one is
AWS End User Messaging.
And AWS End User Messaging
is predominantly used for
multi-channel communications across SMS,
push notifications, and now WhatsApp.
The biggest advantage of that is that
it actually provides a
way for you to actually
take applications that you build on AWS,
and allows you to actually use these APIs
to actually build native integration.
So using a single API stack
along with your application code bases
that you're building in
and leveraging the rest
of the AWS services,
you're now able to deliver messaging.
And one of the reasons
we actually extended this for WhatsApp is
really from an ask from
our customers around,
hey, this is another major channel
of communications that we have.
So customers of all types are looking at
three different ways of
considering messaging,
one is, do I have a dedicated cohort
that I can actually reach
on one particular channel?
More importantly, am I able to deliver
the kind of fidelity that
I need in my messaging,
which is, am I able to
deliver rich communications?
And more importantly for
many parts of the globe,
how's the best way to
actually reach customers
as I need them in different
markets around the world?
So that's one of the
reasons we actually put
AWS end user messaging out there.
Why is this is relevant
for WhatsApp is that,
in your application stack itself,
you now have the ability to manage
various types of interactions
that make it rich,
but at the same time you now have
the ability to actually
drive that reach across.
So using a single WhatsApp number,
I can reach customers all over the globe.
I have that kind of capability,
whereas with SMS I have
to provision things like
SMS long codes and short codes
that actually take time to
provision in many markets.
So that actually is a big reason
why WhatsApp becomes a very big channel.
The other thing is that
I have various types of
restrictions on channels like SMS,
I can send only certain types of content
on certain types of numbers.
WhatsApp gives me this high fidelity
that I can take, as Afeef pointed out,
various types of messages.
So that gives me a single
threaded conversation view
that I can actually take
and actually take those encrypted
communications end-to-end,
and actually feed them
into the rest of my customer
service capabilities.
So now I can actually do certain
interesting stuff with us
that gives me forward thinking capability
and future proof my customer
engagement strategy.
One of the other advantages
of doing these things
is the fact that I'm able to leverage
the same IM security policies that I need.
I'm able to take advantage
of whatever application API
security policies that I've set
and those are now gonna be applied
for my messaging infrastructure
and my messaging capabilities.
And I'm able to take those
deliverability metrics
that are coming across
these channels like WhatsApp
and actually feed them into
a single infrastructure
for me to be able to react to them.
I dunno if I just go to the next slide.
So what does that mean, right?
So we have right now today
a lot of capabilities
that we have built with
open source out there
that you can actually take on GitHub,
where you can actually take conversations
and extend those conversations
where I can create
Agentic AI capabilities.
So I might be able to
create agents on WhatsApp
that can actually help
answer specific questions,
thereby actually relieving the call center
of actually having those conversations.
More importantly, it reacts
and builds a lot more
trust on the channel,
but most importantly, for
brands that are looking
to build relevance with customers,
this becomes a very important channel
because one of the most important things
that you'll realize about WhatsApp is that
it's a very trust earned
channel for customers.
Meaning they can just block you,
and if they block you
then you can't send any messages to them,
any type of messages to them.
So it's a very trust based channel
and I think it bleeds in
very much into the AWS
holistic philosophy of
being able to build secure communications
across the stack.
As far as how to actually
put this together,
you know, I'm gonna invite Bipin
to actually come and share with you
about how you would integrate
this into your applications.
Thanks Bipin.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks Afeef, thanks Venky.
I get to do the more exciting part.
This is why like you got
to the whole frame of like
why WhatsApp, why this
channel is so important,
he touched on many areas of that.
You also kind of in my frame of thought,
like I always think
like the who, what, why,
or like what so what and next what, right?
This is the most interesting part,
like how do we put this together
and I get to talk about that.
At the same time I'm not gonna
do any code walkthroughs,
not writing any code,
and you'll still walk out
thinking like how you could
do this in 10 minutes,
by yourself with no code,
and thanks for the
integration we have in place.
So if you guys are familiar
with AWS ecosystem in general,
like the AWS console itself, this,
what you have is you have
WhatsApp as a integrated channel
as part of your AWS End
User Messaging product.
So when you open AWS
and if you're thinking about
how do I put this integration together,
you simply use the AWS End
User Messaging console.
You have a social
messaging service in that,
you just select that.
Once you enter that,
there's a whole embedded
signup process in that.
Without leaving the ecosystem,
you're now pretty much
a visit driven process
that will walk you through
like either you have a Facebook account,
if yes, you are simply
auth yourself into that.
You got your Facebook account connected,
you have your business
manager accounts in Facebook,
you can select one or you can set one up.
The process is again,
all within this wizard,
you now have your
WhatsApp business account,
you have one or you set one up.
All of this happens right in
the end user messaging console
through the social messaging service.
Once you have all of this set up,
once you confirm all of this,
and trust me, like this is a part
which is actually the most complex step,
but it takes probably five
minutes and 10 for some.
But depending on if you're setting one,
something up very new
or you are just connecting
your existing accounts.
And this is where you get
provisioned with a phone number,
you get provisioned with
like the entire authentication service
with the social messaging
component of WhatsApp.
And within the end user messaging service,
you're basically verifying your number,
which is also pretty straightforward.
You are provisioned through
the end user messaging API now,
and this is a point where
you pretty much have
your plumbing in place,
you've got AWS and WhatsApp
talking to each other now.
And this is where now
you get to the programmatic aspect of it.
Depending on your business use case flows,
you could pretty much
connect with the Amazon SNS
or Amazon Connect.
These are the two services
you can easily connect and configure.
And you can pretty much have
an event driven automation
or using AWS Lambda
to trigger messages
based on realtime events
from your application
or other trigger points,
and directly with the agent
console on Amazon Connect.
Go either ways.
Again, this is like,
think of it as like the
Lego blocks are in place
and you could construct,
orchestrate your use case flow
the way you might imagine.
But you got two big
ecosystems and platforms
already connected and
talking to each other.
Now, this is where I wanna make sure
like you guys understand,
like it's not about just the construct of
enabling your use case but,
which is good, but now you
also have right out of the box
is all of the analytics,
the observability,
the ability to learn about your message
and all of those things
once you are WhatsApp account
and the event messages flow through.
You can actually automatically
start scaling this
because again, you don't
have to worry about
the infra behind all of this.
You can just start scaling
your real world use cases right away
once this integration is in place.
What it also allows you to do is like
send, also automated,
like as Afeef I think already touched upon
some very nice use cases
where you could send real
time updates about your orders
as soon as a e-commerce event happens,
or let's say a cancellation happens
or a scheduling, the update happens,
you can route almost some of these things.
Again, the reason I brought
up a AWS Lambda and SNS is,
like you could pretty much
have your own orchestration
of this, if this, then that
and WhatsApp is nothing but an event point
or a channel that you may
think that can be triggered
by one of these events when
they satisfy the conditions.
And you can track the whole performance
of this entire orchestration,
which is your AWS console now
allows you to get insights on
your entire message payload,
the entire message journey
through its lifecycle,
the number of messages that I send,
the number of templates
you're working with,
the tags, and whatnot thereof.
Like so you have down
the grain auditability
of all of your messages
that are happening through
this implementation now.
At this point I wanna pass on to Afeef
to walk you through some case studies.
- Thank you so much Bipin.
So I mentioned earlier on
that there are 600
million daily interactions
between businesses and
customers on WhatsApp already.
So I wanted to illustrate a
couple of those case studies
so you guys can see
how our business is taking
advantage of WhatsApp.
So the first example here
is a hospital network
in Indonesia called Siloam hospitals.
In Indonesia WhatsApp is,
it's kind of the communication protocol
that most people use already
for consumer communication.
So it really made sense for a business,
in this case a healthcare business
to try to get in touch
with their customers
in that same channel that
they're already using.
Prior to using WhatsApp,
Siloam, for all communications
with their customers,
whether it was to remind
them about appointment,
whether it was to schedule appointment,
they were doing it largely
through email and calls,
but they realized that
they weren't doing it
in the most efficient way.
And so they actually moved
all of their communication over to,
all of their customer
communication over to WhatsApp.
And they saw some really
great results out of this.
They saw an 8% increase
in appointment bookings
after launching automated messaging.
They saw really notably a 36% increase
in self-patient check-ins,
you know, because the prompts
were sent in WhatsApp saying,
Hey, you've got an appointment
coming up tomorrow,
fill out this paperwork
before your appointment.
As you can imagine, this
saved significant resources
and time of people being at that,
being at the hospital
and not needing to fill
out paperwork there.
And finally, when customer
service inquiries came through
previously they were taking a week
for all of those inquiries to be tackled,
after implementing WhatsApp
for all of their
communication with customers,
80% of cases were actually
able to be dealt with
within 24 hours.
And so in this instance, Siloam Hospitals,
they did this largely
through utility messages,
but also marketing messages as well.
One other case study
I wanted to highlight,
this is a Brazilian
digital bank called PicPay.
So as a digital bank with
no physical footprint,
it was really important for PicPay
to be able to do the customer onboarding
and the security verification
of that individual
with, you know, digitally.
And so the issue that PicPay had was
previously they were doing this over SMS
and they found that a lot of customers
were not completing the onboarding,
and so they wanted to move
that over to WhatsApp.
They started servicing the
OTP passcodes through WhatsApp
and they saw a 3.5% increase
in customers onboarding
and then also a 6.5% increase
in verification rates.
So this is, you know, another illustration
of a totally different use
case from Siloam hospitals,
and here they were using a
different message type as well.
They were using authentication
messages exclusively,
whereas in the previous example, you know,
I was showing largely utility messages,
but there were some marketing
messages from Siloam.
If you remember from when
I was speaking earlier,
the businesses that see the best value
out of their investment in WhatsApp
are those that use multiple message types.
You can imagine that in
the example with Siloam,
because they were getting
appointment reminders,
if there was then, you
know, a marketing message,
I'll make like an American example of it,
hey, it's a December
have you used all of your
healthcare benefits, right?
Someone is more likely to
interact with that message
when they've received messages before
that remind them about
what their appointment,
remind them about their
appointment reminders.
So, you know, to sum up here,
I hope that you all
have learned a lot about
the different messaging
types that WhatsApp employs
and how that can enable a
business to get in touch
with the customer through any element
and in fact every element
of the customer journey.
And in fact WhatsApp I would say
enriches each of those elements
of the customer journey as well.
My call to action to you all
is it's pretty simple actually,
you know, get started
with WhatsApp business.
If you're a business that's thinking about
how you can get in touch with customers
in a different way, try it out.
As Bipin and Venky talked about,
we have a native integration with AWS,
so if you're an existing AWS customer,
you literally just need
to go to the console,
you can get set up within
about 10 or 15 minutes
and have your WhatsApp
business account provision
directly within the AWS console.
Additionally, for anyone
that wants to learn more,
we have a booth, Booth875,
and you can go down there
and there's some touchscreens
where you can play around
with those different message types.
Again, the marketing utility,
authentication and service messages
so you could see what a message flow
would look like with businesses.
And in addition, we have
more case studies there
for you to learn about it.
So with that, thank you
all so much for your time.
I hope this is beneficial for you all
and I hope to see you guys
using WhatsApp business.
(attendees applauding)